what for the Republic we finally get to
see what the plate of action fix and
what we're looking at here you know
we've looked at a couple different
theories so what that might makes right
through some ACCA's in Plato we looked
at egoism and contract eeriness on the
last class with Locke and Etta mantis
somebody I think in this class pointed
out that contract erotism actually does
presuppose egoism now we're going to
move into virtue ethics we want to think
about this is a moral theory so it's a
theory that's telling us about what's
good in habits right and wrong and you
know the word for issue Kent gets it
away what is it about virtue is going to
be the key thing this is not a term that
we've used a lot recently in our society
I need to suspect that if any of you
came across this recently it was outside
of you know reading Victorian literature
and to deal with sexual context it
probably was if you were doing some sort
of so we can cases right because
churches most people don't use these
words so what is a virtue well a virtue
if you want to be really really generic
about this some sort of
first so what does this mean what does
it mean to have character means that the
person consistently a certain way so if
we talk about somebody being just that
means that they're not just once in a
while that means that the pattern of
their behaviour is just they are just if
not all the time at least most of the
time it also means another thing which
is that it's based what they value so
you know if you're a good person if
you're a just person only because you're
trying to stand in trouble because you
can punish a lot when you're a kid
you're not really a just person you're
behaving just like we don't have a
character trait being just because as
soon as they no longer in danger and
being punished what do you do whatever
you want right even if that's unjust in
order to be virtuous that has to become
part of the fabric of who you are now
we've given virtues if you get a good
character traits what else could you
have a bad character beautiful thank
Allah for you know these are things that
are actually agreeing in a person as
well they become part of who that person
yes so somebody is unjust it's not just
that they they behaved a bit once or you
know very occasionally it's like you can
count on that to be a
first you can count on that to do the
wrong thing it's kind of Samsung's kind
of strange if you can actually count
them right you can say you can't count
on them to do the right thing you can't
count that and why are we going to do
this well again this is perfect who they
got this gets to do with what they value
and if somebody is unjust it's because
and it's become part of who they are
that's gonna skew the way in which they
they see the world of the people goods
their relationships there's somebody
becomes a miser right and they don't
exhibit the virtue of generosity they
exhibit vice of skin genus they're
always holding on defense attorney just
accumulate more they don't want to they
don't want to give anybody anything why
do they do everybody ask them why do you
have that one and they'll say things
like it's dog-eat-dog world everybody's
gonna look out for themselves that's a
few point right and if you have that
sort of viewpoint that's going to affect
the way you you deal with those where
you might point out to them hey you know
you could spend some money on your kids
you know your kids are wearing rags you
got tons of money in a bank account why
don't you buy him some new clothes so
the other kids aren't making fun of them
at school and they can say well money is
more important that's a sign of what
they value right so so people who have
vices they have certain patterns of
behavior they also certain cádiz of
motivation same thing virtuous
so what are some some virtues what are
some devices let's make a list choose
devices I hit you write down some quick
questionnaire some quick answers off the
top your head into question what are
some good character traits of people
over some bad character traits over
people let's actually start the
batteries what do they
I think that's different have any any
other ones that didn't make this list
okay okay so I thought maybe sometimes
people use that words that need
something like gently something like
that are harsher than they need to be
cuz you have to make some choices right
otherwise you couldn't vicious character
what's up conceited probably something
similar
I'm a bad speller misspelling thing let
me know okay so these are you know these
are traits that can all of you agree
more or less as a class means as traits
you wouldn't want and a friend and a
roommate
somebody that you have to share space
with yeah what's that
so they present one side to you but they
actually behave sometimes that's a tiny
jump good to be judgmental
well what about pictures what do you
guys we get luck what do you want in a
person what would you want in a friend
or a roommate or potential yeah there's
actually one second because I do want to
say something about yeah well there's a
guy we were not reading for this class
Josiah Royce who he actually thought
that loyalty is the basis of all ethics
and he will report entirely about
loyalty and tying it together so I think
that's very important
well yeah so we're starting to see
opposites some of the other vices right
what else any other traits that you
actually say no doesn't talk about that
Aristotle who are going to read later on
talks about virtues having to do with
our socialization and being somebody is
enjoyable year-round consistently is
actually a virtual kind of alignment for
true but you know it's not the same
thing to say on courage of justice but
yeah yeah
truthfully what we've got there with
honest but now one thing that's kind of
interesting being honest or being
deceptive there's more than one way to
do that right there's ways to tell a
true story in one sense that's actually
kind of false that's something we're not
going to spoil it it's an interesting
room for one more
somebody wants okay that's very
interesting
you notice if you look at these lists
some of what Plato is talking about a
book for a line is pretty closely with
it with some of these a lot of these
dumped and there are some things that
played a hand in at the end before he
talks about virtues he had devices that
are not showing up on his lists nobody
said I want a friend who was just a
friend was courageous
there's temperates moderates or
something like that somebody did say I
want prayer who's knowledgeable and
that's that's kind of close to Plato's
wisdom or Aristotle's practice somebody
who knows things that they need to know
here I guess would be the often times we
pray in terms of wisdom unfortunate
foolishness is the opposite of wisdom
there's a lot of virtues on here and a
lot of vices on here that Plato doesn't
talk very much I think he would roll
them into justice like being honest for
example that's the part of being just
Fairplay being dishonest that's part of
being the virtue that
trustworthy respectful level be part of
justice patient and kind they you know
he could talk about that I suppose but
it doesn't go I think there's a
difference between our society and Plato
society now if I if I were to do this
class in other contexts other virtues
and vices like like if you guys were a
military class or some of my prison
students you can bet that courage and
cowardice will come up on these lists
but good
one of the things that I want to start
actually yeah I've always like thought
about this when thinking of like what
people think are wrong and right what if
somebody's what we think are their vices
are actually virtue to that well that's
a good question there's a sense of vice
and virtue where it would just be
socially approved trains right that's
the case then it's sort of up for grabs
like some societies see
and not backing down from anything hmm
as a virtue most societies that a
functional don't but there are some that
let's see that the fact that they would
see that as a good thing it's different
than saying that actually is a bit there
are some vices that masquerade as
virtues we're gonna see this form when
we get to Aristotle like for example
rashness or full darkness the
willingness to jump into any sort of
conflict whatsoever that's not real
courage it looks like right if you're
not careful it's easy to mix them up and
it's really easy to contrast that to say
coward's way out but genuine courage
requires more than just messes it might
actually require not carry so we have
these measures that we cannot reproduce
you're right though there is there is a
problem there there are different people
don't all see the virtues and vices the
same way I guess the short answer to
that would be that this may not be
satisfying at this point of the semester
some people are mistaken about the way
actually it's virtually people better
understand but that presupposes right
then we actually understand that may not
satisfy know that that was actually well
this is oh that's a good question this
is a real issue
lemme so we have versions and yeah but
and I guess the previous class these
same questions and I would like to see
if you guys come up with more or less
the same
so I think
what do you mean though one of the
things I stress to last classes
you really should be judgemental in a
certain way and I guess the caption it
was a bit good were standing up for what
you actually think is right because it
is what's actually put the other unduly
critical of people tearing them down all
the time friendly okay okay now what
don't you like friends roommates spouses
eventually shot eager ignorant
what's your nose and by that we mean to
orient it towards dirt you know what
it could be dirtier than like it out
perverted I mean when we talk about
plays think about you know what is the
vice squad actually go after drugs
prostitution we usually associate advice
of sexual lady - you mean like somebody
who's always
this project if we manage to roll these
all into one person we have just what an
awful roommate they would make maybe
somebody you bet them I don't know
now it's interesting if I compare this
to the previous class the lists are
almost identical almost because there's
certain core things in our society that
then this point goes here for your
question we're certain core things in
our society and I think in most
societies that are going to be
acknowledged as vices and certain things
are going to be acknowledged as that's
virtuous flavor doesn't actually talk
about all of these many of these can be
rolled into say justice justice now
notice one of the things that came up is
intelligent irrational and then ignorant
some mental qualities some things having
to do with how well you think about
things can't be virtuous replaces and
they are foreplay to this passionate one
the being do not over the standing up
for what it is if you actually believe
the other class didn't love them they
didn't have something like that I would
say that that's something similar to
Plato's call courage and we'll see why
why they also didn't come up with
unfamiliar hygienic as a bottle I think
there's when people don't bathe for days
on end
there's usually something going on
some part of their makeup okay
they've hit laziness I think they
thought they had a few that weren't on
here they didn't have laziness that's
another interesting one but most of the
rest a very simple that's probably good
tonight
it's a sign that you're in attunement
with you know other people in your
society good humor I wanted to dimension
just very quickly
Aristotle later on we were looking at
this during the last few weeks of the
semester he talked about Buddha humors
virtue
because there's burchett virtues of
sociability these are all very good
so here's a wrap
I was the posthuman so let's see dirty
full cars lots of streets in it big
buildings what makes the city where do
recent thinking about as a physical
place right yeah
very good it's the people no people no
city all you've got it you know if you
don't have people there is a bunch of
buildings and some stop people that make
the city so Plato talks about the city
is being composed this is an ideal but
you couldn't transpose it in other
places too there are certain functions
that have to be carried on with that
city if you want to live together it's
not just throwing a whole bunch of
people together and saying you know just
make things work there's certain basic
functions that if human beings are going
to work together and live together and
all that have to plan out somebody has
to be doing this what are these these
really basic functions let's say I threw
all of you together on some desert
what do you need yeah yeah you need some
people to protect the city to keep order
that's a you know like police or
military is something like that somebody
who bears our arms we can use deadly
force in purposes of the city cities and
they'd like your stuff you know the
Greek world you had you didn't have one
big unified country get all these little
city-states so think about say for
example the Kip see right can see it's
pretty sizable and it keeps in Hyde Park
and then right away right okay so the
Kip see Hyde Park right back imagine
that each one of them this is all
country they have their own laws they
may have a long history going back but
like fighting wars with each other
taking each other's stuff they don't
always get along that's the way ancient
Greece was Athens was a dominance every
once in a while they'd all get together
to fight some common end like a Persian
some of you may have seen
mainly about the sparkles but that was
the way there though and you have some
sort of protective force and you know
they need a protective force against
outsiders there's always going to be
some people doing what they're not
supposed to do that city right so you
have to have some sort of police what
are you gonna shell turd
we need all sorts of other things
play-doh actually goes through this
whole exercise where Socrates lays out
very simple city and then lock it and
they had a mantis in four markets well
that doesn't sound like very good life
oh I didn't know that you want the city
swollen with luxury they said well let's
give them all you know let people to
make perfume and Weaver's and people are
going to have a market place and people
who do selling and buying on the
marketplace will meet all these people
who provide the necessities what else do
you need though yeah but they don't
ultimately provide it you get this some
sort of rulers yeah you know somebody
who makes laws and who says here's how
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
allocate these resources here and you
know the Kip see
Kingston but I imagine you've got mayor
and the City Council and something along
those lines here on campus who's who's
in charge could be the thing would be
the protection but who's they actually
who calls the shot to new hires and
fires the security is very right you
have a president and there's vice
presidents and that it goes all the way
down you know with professors sort of
just one step of walking students and
trustees and the trustees can actually
boot the president out in some places
some schools you know the president
every couple of years the trustees those
are the rulers they're the ones who
decide the policy do you have to have
all these things in order for a city to
work now can things go wrong with this
yeah wait a ruler's can be dropped can't
that you've all seen that occur our
police or soldiers or prison guards or
other people who do protective services
do they ever this is a big issue some of
your CJ majors and we talked about this
a little bit before what about these
other things that people get mixed up
about these you know do these poorly
yeah now
in Plato's ideal city there's there's
kind of hierarchy there is that always
the case in real cities you might have a
police running the show military the
commercial people yeah you know I mean
think about our argument what's the
biggest complaints made from both right
and left corporations have too much
power corporations are commercial
interests right yeah because of the way
our because they so maybe the rulers
don't actually rule maybe they take
orders that may not be the best way to
do things
Plato says that this is why those human
soul there's a metaphor here the soul
yes its parts as well what are the one
of the parts of the soul well maybe
they're three or maybe than four maybe
they're
how do we tell what these parts of the
soul are well first of all what does he
mean how many does he actually
is it going to be the things it did play
for there are four virtues are there
four parts of the soul for playing I
mean you might think well there's four
virtues it must be four parts next soul
justice is a different yeah yeah I want
to say a little bit about each of these
things desire is pretty straightforward
sometimes you'll see it call appetite as
well and that's what we're doing
translating Greek word at the Fumiya
which means sort of like the you know
desire or the yearning for something so
if you liked coffee you have a desire
for content for coffee and if somebody
giving you t is not going to cut it
right like if well we all have certain
appetites we all need food drink a while
to myself you know I'm gonna sleep right
now you need to sleep sometimes well
that's a desire right yeah some of the
desires are bodily and some of them
might just be mental most of the
Americans are things we feel from the
body you have a whole set of sexual
desires which are actually if let's put
a lot like by your mind because mental
because culture but the basic drive
itself that's what they're translating
here is spirit sometimes it's also
called the passionate part of the
smaller they call passion the word is
the most and this is a really hard word
in translate and another legitimate
translation for it is anger or the part
of your soul that gets angry sometimes
they call this the irascible part of the
soul the person gets angry and then this
reason in greek that logos and think
back to you know when you were a kid
your biology or your anthropology or
whatever classes you're taking that had
mythology and then they said well this
comes from the Greek word you know what
were they or were they telling you that
comes from the Greek word logos what
they say hello to us man
yeah study
and you know you do that with bracelets
it's a part of your your soul that
thinks that considers that weighs
options back and forth it's not the
sirens part of the soul spirited part of
the soul that's the part that is
actually rational interestingly the
Greek word logos also means speech this
is what differentiates us from the other
animals we are animals right the animals
designers we have designers I'm gonna
box auntie Mahina box this morning they
do the same thing every morning under
the food bowl and eat it too fast
choking into that one you know speed a
little bit slower but they're done right
I know they were 37 years old and they
still do the same thing well they don't
have a reason you can sit a kid down I
was eating too fast and saying hey knock
it off
eat a little slower we're you know we're
different from the other animals in that
you can talk to each other and we can
read them things out and this is a good
thing it can also give very manic to it
is we can also plan to kill each other
much more efficiently we can get into
lots of arguments and disagreements we
die to each other animals they can do
some things that are deceptive but they
can't like actually plan out how to lie
to another animal whereas we can do that
we have
Frank had somebody some of them more
serious like jeepers but we have these
parts of our soil and plate of things
that there's a correspondence between
these parts of our soul and these parts
of the city and the correspondence isn't
that difficult to see what a rulers need
do they need to you know you really
strong in the body think about you know
the people that made I'm running a show
here in the United States or most of
them in trying to physical condition I
used to be a joke
back then you guys were all really young
President Clinton real Incas
what do you want to you want somebody
who has this part of their soul
developed think we can consider the
figures things out who can actually
explain themselves to other people what
do you want in those who kind of
protective do you need somebody who's
really brilliant probably as a matter of
fact if you're too smart that may
actually be a handicap if you're in
your situation do you think all the time
and you have to react and save people's
lives or don't up to them bad guys you
know sort of thinking out the situation
the whole time
it may be over by the time you know what
you need is this part of your small that
gets angry or has the fight response the
part of us that that can feel courage
the part of us that can rise to the two
dangers that has to be developed right
why do we need all these other things
food shelter other necessities luxuries
that mean because we have desires the
desire is part of the soul Plato
associates with everybody else the
trains
and probably know that we actually do
have this Parsley's this is kind of a
metaphor isn't it to all of you by this
would be about you
you're gonna be in you according to put
it of soul or if you don't like that
because it's on us to be illogical say
you're the personalities these are the
parts of your personality parts of who
you are does it seem reasonable to you
then you have got one single unified
thing all the time to go different parts
yeah
just speaking personally I feel like
those are the only three early I connect
or on the other one to send them one
more time because I think I lost the
training that I think I lost it don't
wanna sleep but I don't think that
that's all there is to a person's
personality or soul there should be more
okay yeah there may well be there might
be some aspects of us I think if we
looked at them carefully we might be
able to some of them we might be able to
find ways to do business let's look at
the argument now clearly or why we
should think
so he says never going to actually read
we're thinking about our so he asks
whether we do all these things with the
same thing or whether there are three
things and we do one thing with one and
one with another learn with one part of
ourselves feel anger with another with
yet a third desire the pleasures of
nutrition and generation the kind or
whether it is with the entire soul that
we function in each case women must
begin so it does your personality does
your soul who you are do you entirely
commit yourself are you entirely there
in everything that you do or are you
it's always divided either other parts
of yourself that do this otherwise
you're soft
do this and he's not really asking you
know do you give like one Facebook
friends on Facebook
relatives or anything that could fit
into it he's asking are you in some
sense divided and that you've got
different functions and not always
present insane playing for each one
yeah he says this is really hard to
determine the property this is not an
easy question to it to explore he says
let's attach a binary decide whether
they're identical with each with one
another in this way so one way to get at
us this isn't the only way to get one
way to go says it's obvious the same
thing will never do or suffered
opposites in the same respect in
relation to thinking at the same time we
find a contradiction if you find
yourself feeling two different ways at
the same time or feeling and thinking
and most not exactly giant that's an
experience Plato says that shows you
that you have different parts of your
soul so one of the first kind of
conflicts that can come on the other
side is right what kind of desires how
many of you would like to go
only only recorders in the class movie
are well-rested
why aren't why don't we just do that
right now would you know it's 8:45 today
done with it why don't we do that
because my boss will get off the case
probably right where you'd say well we
all desire to learn hopefully okay it's
a it's a core class at this point can
you do you have desires so you have
multiple desires right and desires can
conflict' with each other like you might
have a desire for sleep I have another
desire
what else could keep your sleep yeah
yeah so reason you could have a conflict
between reason and desire reason can
tell you that he and I have a state here
learn something more hey I'm paying this
guy to actually show up two and a half
hours a week and you know lead us
through these things I'd like to
actually have them here two and a half
hours a week not you know an hour and a
half a week that's reasonable right and
reason can conflictive designer your
desires can also conflict with each
other to want to sleep and at the same
time there's a show on and then you
watch another show and you know there's
there's another show after that and then
pretty soon a three in the morning right
you may have experienced that recently I
don't know
those are conflicting designers you
could want to go eat Lynette you're also
presented with something that appeals to
you or your drive for for sense right
you could go eat or you could go talk to
that attractive person over there you're
really hungry but they're really
attractive
and reason could actually save you you
know there's another fish in the ocean
and a really hungry right now you better
go eat reason could could take a role
right is that all there is to it or all
the conflicts that we have between
reasonable and designer famous as well
you might think that but can we have
other reason is not emotional designers
are
is there another effective emotional
part of ourselves that can yeah
and he has this example of somebody who
has this desire it's on the battlefield
to look at you know some gross things
corpses and he felt that that was kind
of shameful so he allows himself to
indulge that desire angry at himself
yeah at the same time from doing that
the anger that he's feeling is something
different they on the designer that he's
feeling out of a different part of his
his salt the the spirited part of our
soul is concerned with how we feel about
ourselves
it wants to be looked up to or admired
or liked by other people it's concerned
with the
fight response it's the part of us that
gets roused up when we have to face some
sort of danger or stand up to something
scary or dangerous or we have to take a
stand
but that's something different than just
the designers you know you can you could
want to eat or want to have sex or want
to watch TV that's not enough to
actually get you to stand up in the face
of something scary Plato thinks we need
another part of your soul
when your designers we're into position
well talk about this as temperance
moderation
we don't use we're temperance how many
further what if what do you associate
that yeah you know why historically
exactly and the temperance movement they
were playing off of the fact that
templates met more than just about
drinking they were mainly about trying
to curb drinking because it's still a
big problem today really getting a lot
of trouble because prohibition cast not
just because people will approve but
temperance can apply to other things too
I mean drinking is probably a good
example service what happens if he
drinks when drinking was not a bad thing
but it's alright yeah you know you may
get sick yeah that's trying to drink to
get drunk
that's right talking about how people
have good side and the bad side usually
bad sides as figures and the good side
the goal is to be able to actually be
the master of that bad side and control
it by being good and temperance meant
like saying
from drinking drugs prostitution
according to him so it's being able to
control your desires
yeah is having a temper played over a
minute
I mean Socrates goes to drinking one-one
dialogue called the symposium which
means getting together to drink right
then and apparently Socrates can't
imagine that he wasn't you know totally
a mystery but he would say he's gotta
have it within certain limits
prostitution it was much better
prostitution much but he just talked a
lot about sex and sexual desire yeah
again he would say you know not too much
doesn't mean that you don't have any of
that but you know you know we can
usually go too far here's the thing with
the desires every single one of them is
on its own sort of Robert Rose desire
for something and it won't set limits on
itself it'll keep on telling you so
think about the physical desires that
that we I used an example and the other
class values for this one the cafeteria
right if you wanted to indulge yourself
in the cafeteria here and there's you
could and you know you could you could
go over there and you could get there at
11 o'clock and not leave until two
o'clock for lunch and start off with the
main entree get some pizza and then get
the salad bar one of the soups one of
the three soups that they always get out
let me take that back to you table start
yeah go back for another soup hit the
pasta bar go back your table go back
again
they've hamburger get the other soup
that's
thing right and finish it up with you
know they've got the deserts have a
desert and then maybe to interfere and
you know they get different kinds of a
scream so after you finish your bowl of
mint chocolate chip
a some cookie dough and that would also
do you like maybe some but no one with
peanuts and caramel sounds pretty good
and your desires would keep on telling
you hey yeah some more I mean your body
will actually ascertain might say I
can't take but your body if your desires
control your body your desires will
change your body people who over in
dollars their stomachs actually get
larger they can fit more food in their
stomach it changes same thing with
drinking I mean drink enough and then
your you will need more or with drugs
you'll need more whatever it is yeah my
600-pound and even when she got down to
160 she said the urges were so bad to
eat that's interest she got down to 160
yeah no nobody say the urges we're still
there because they're part of your if
you don't like the word small you could
say personality right your psyche or
without the part of who you are playing
those plans if you indulge your desires
they will grow they will they will get
bigger and bigger and bigger I know this
from my own experience I'm the kind of
person to walk and goes to excessive
lunch excessive exercise and went to
excessive food back in graduate school
was a hard-drinking school so they don't
too accessible yeah
relationships many of us you know and
South very quickly because excesses of
one form or another in my song for the
other person and it's true I can tell
you from experience if you indulge your
desires they will get bigger than they
currently are it's only if you can put
limits on them of some sort and the
desires themselves can't do that it's
only if you can put limits on them of
some sort that they'll actually remain
constant or in check if you do that then
you can start to develop techniques for
moderation and you know to become really
a temperate or moderate means those
things don't have control so you can go
to the bar and you can have one or two
or perhaps three or four drinks
you can go to the big you know fancy
dinner and indulge yourself and then not
I'm building yourself the next day you
can say that's okay you know you can you
control what you do with those desires
and their objects rather than those
control the music's away
and that's a virtue could you become
temporary or moderate just because
somebody tells you to sure you don't
people look good does that make them
tempter no because as soon as you let
them out they'll go out and you know if
you want to control some of these
proclivities to get themselves into
affairs harsh none for you know or maybe
reward them for not doing but then take
away that much of it or the warden and
they go right back to their own activity
unless they have changed right you know
originally punishment reward could be
useful for getting a process started but
that's not gonna work by itself sooner
or later that person has to choose that
they have to say that's a good thing
let's think about the spirit of art
later says that courage yes
now think about let's start up and
thinking about the kind of people that
are expected to show courage Society in
ancient Greek society the exemplar
exemplar replacement yeah yeah and the
guardians are for Plato Arthur like bold
and our hand a police force a decent and
to be in a Greek army at that time was
you know very different I mean nowadays
being with guns and grenades and all
sorts of high-tech stuff you can shoot
people from the 400 yards away
one evening it's not it's not quite the
same breed conflict which meant that you
actually in any shield and long spear
and you were in there with a whole bunch
of other guys and you would run into the
other guy Ram a spear through the guts
of people in front of you while they
were trying to do that to you and
sometimes your spear break and you have
to get out of sorts hacking away at them
while they're trying to do that
pretty bad you know you know it's one
thing to shoot somebody it's a whole
other thing to run something through
them while they're trying to do that to
you that scares people and that scared
them that guy I mean they they had to
talk themselves up to do it and it took
a lot of work sometimes some of them ran
away but that's where they thought
current is a good most discipline but
where else is in this play well think
about our society you don't have people
doing that sort of thing we do have
military fighting police being a
policeman you know that takes courage
maybe not to get a desk job to actually
confront people who are doing the wrong
thing people who are doing the wrong
thing I don't know that makes people
right and when you tell them they're
doing the right thing
how do they react do they say how old
you're right I realize the error of my
ways
it'll stop doing this we get angry at
you they want to get you and draw the
attention of an insult you know even if
you're just doing your you're taking
care of crowds at the fair there's
always some drunk person it's a beauty a
guy who wants to start trouble right so
it takes this kind of courage as well I
think about firefighters it takes
courage to be a firefighter you gotta go
into a burning building wearing all this
stuff that slows you down and makes you
feel like you're suffocating while your
body and your desires are telling you
get the hell out of there what are you
crazy it's that spirit of part that
allows you to do that because your
desires are
it's that part of you that actually has
different kinds of desires desires or
something higher what else discourage
not all of us are firefighters he said
it as very old Journal and you so don't
waiver his other injuries yeah I mean if
you were changing your opinion all the
time just to get food I mean a big thing
back in the Greek important types of
dinner parties and sort of selling
yourself out as intellectual and saying
that you know which people were really
smart or greater things like that's it
yeah that's you know boxing I remember
when I was when I was in high school I
had to run the 400 meters I hated it and
my coach decided that I should be a 440
400 runner because of my body
you're like he would make you a 220 yeah
he would make you a 440 whether you
would be in a while runner you'd be most
likely discus thrower
don't worry I mean for miles
you know and I hear Tommy to Rockefeller
that you got the wrong dad
and you never true because he was the
company and I hated doing hurt because
you guys call him gym class right she
probably all the run the 400 it's not
like running a sprint and start out at a
sprint and you run right so you get to
the first 100 meter mark and now you're
feeling good because your body's your
sprint technology into the 220 market
like yeah I'm going pretty good now here
too and then all lactic acids are
spilling out of your body at that 30
second right because anaerobic activity
can go for about 30 seconds and then now
you're you're drawing on all your
reserves and now will you start getting
into the third party and now your breath
slower and your guts start hurting and
your legs are cramping up and all these
other people running alongside you're
feeling the same thing but you're all
trying get all motivated by the superior
part of you not to you know not to quit
not to look you know like you're like
you're weaker than the other people and
I need to that last part and they call
that the bear because it literally feels
like you're being torn apart if you're
doing it right and you just try to get
your then now the last part of it you
know it's really painful and I would I
wouldn't have to psych myself up each
track me cuz I had to we had a small
team so I had to run both the 440 and
then at the end of the battery so thank
you once and then do it again yeah I
might have to psych myself up I was
afraid of that pain I hate it I wanted
so badly to be either a mile runner or a
sprinter
that's like and that's what have lennick
things yeah that would be an example of
that spirited part of your soul that
that competitive part of your soul
standing up for what you believe is
right that's difficult to do is about
especially if your other designers are
in sync if you are at risk of losing or
losing on us it's tough isn't it in that
case and this could be as trivial as
somebody says bad things about your a
friend you want to fit in but at the
same time know that these things are
wrong did you actually do it you stand
up for do you give in now how do you
develop courage by behaving in a
courageous way even when you're scared
and you have to do it over and over and
over again
and then eventually it becomes part of
your character like like for instance
when I first started teaching my hands
would actually show I think a lot of you
right but you do it long enough and
eventually you get used to it and you
actually come to like it
what happens if you don't do that what
happens if you give
probably well that's the short-term what
can't wait
yeah because each time if something
you're faced with an opportunity
temperate or not to be temperate to
create this or not be courageous you are
determining a little bit of your
character for the future so if you don't
stand up to the bully the first time it
may be harder to stand up to the bully
the next time eventually may have made
it on four mice of colors and it may be
impossible for you stand up to anybody
we become what we do play the visitors
it's the same yeah what about the next
version we talked about that what does
it mean to be wise I mean this is a term
that we throw around
oh that's very good today is my wedding
okay yeah that would be having the
virtue of wisdom that part of your soul
which Plato says is the smallest part
calling the shots
deciding before the other person this is
what you want to do this is figuring out
what the right thing to do is at the
time that's that's being wise figuring
out whether that's also one reason why
we tend to associate wisdom with the age
one reason why we do this associated
with it you no longer use experience
things the more you've got to draw on
you might develop
so each part of the soul has its own
virtue and then what are we missing
what's the other purchase somebody's
hanging honor justice
right and justice is not just one part
of small earlier it's something that has
to do with the whole the personal whole
how all the parts are related there's
two ways to think about one is if you're
going to be just so if you're going to
be the kind of person who does the right
thing characteristically because that's
the kind of person that you are you're
going to need these other merchants
you're right about your lack and wisdom
it's probably going to be difficult for
you just as you're going to what's the
opposite of wisdom foolishness you're
going to make the wrong decisions if you
don't have the courage to actually see
them through that's going to be a
problem - you're going to hard time
getting just if you are pressuring the
unjust if you're not courageous you're
going to have a very hard time being
just if you don't have some control
desire us because one of the things of
your desires might want to do well think
about the things that we consider to be
unjust or steal white people steal they
want stuff right I mean I suppose they
could steal just to screw somebody else
over or to make them feel bad or
something like that and that would
probably be more the problem with the
spirit of partners all right but in
general a lot of people steal because
they want what other people have and
they're unable to control their sight
there's not a problem
line stuff but wanting some stuff too
much so that it leads you to do bad
things that would not only be injustice
what are other desires babies will sleep
with each other's boyfriends and
girlfriends husband's console
cheating being on the other side Gina I
know why do people do that again it
could because yeah I'm going to show him
probably more spirited from angry but
why do people do with the first boss
they might have sex and there they were
unwilling to say I should just have sex
with this one person who have you know
made some sort of commitment right I
shouldn't sleep with other people much
and seduce other people that are in
committed relationships you can think of
all sorts of variations if your desires
are not in some sort of control they're
controlling you you're going to be
lended you on just things what about
this part or did this go wrong - could
you be too aggressive
yeah could you be too competitive to
desires that can happen to right again
if you're if you're not able to figure
out the other extreme you're not able to
stand up for yourself or from what's
right we have a very hard time being
just aren't you other people where your
desires will control you get you to do
things
yeah yeah if you're getting in fights
all the time that's not where the
courage
that's Florence I'll tell you an
interesting story I'll tell you - yeah
actually two stories about courage one
actually not like it's Martin Luther
King's one of the things that people
don't know about Martin Luther King and
the marchers is that they deliberately
busted people and then cultivated
courage in workshops before they what
they would do is is there you have like
that get a school and they'd say okay
who wants to March come to the school
and we're going to do this these
training exercises and they would you'd
have to walk down the line and they you
know punch you or push you and say
horrible things and you know try to act
like people would do a march right and
then they would see whether you've got
scared and ran away or whether you went
to the other extreme and started hitting
people or yelling back if you fell into
that that's it you can't March with us
we don't need that sort of thing we you
need people who are actually courageous
and of course why do they keep doing
this because that's why they don't do it
because it took that's what courage
abuse here's another story I used to
work in a Kentucky Fried Chicken I was
in high school back then I was kind of I
had problems with my spirit heart muscle
and that's done fear of like beans so I
was really into martial arts and there
was this guy who he was probably in his
late 20s and he was where he started
working at our Kentucky Fried he
transferred it from a syllabic place and
then he was saying so you're into
martial arts on honey tide change that's
cool
that guy was studying karate and he said
you want to learn to cheat and I said
yeah that'd be great
they said okay so you wrote down this
thing out a piece of paper so here meet
me here the address bar we're asleep
that cheetah bar said well yeah what we
do is we women practices we're doing in
to start fights and that's when we do
Tai Chi if you never give these mutts
bed sheet that's not what he was calling
night chief but this is what this guy
would do regular like once a week you
keep going start a bar fight he ended up
later than that so that's that's a part
of his character right being foolhardy
you didn't get currently at for later on
one of the big ovens look down it's
called the 10 320
and so this is our workhorse yeah if
that goes down the restaurants a lot of
trouble
what are you supposed to do machines
that should fix it yourself that's
that's what this dough will tell you to
do and that's what the manager told him
to do
leave it alone well this guy said I
think I can fix it so he went in and he
he fixed himself pretty good electrocute
himself ended up being a vegetable
actually get it unplugged wisdom
would've told you if you're you know if
you are going to disobey the rules and
work on the machine that you're not
remotely qualified to repair unplug it
first right didn't do that and the
consequence because he wasn't courageous
he was full heart he would jump into
things
okay so justice requires that you have
all these it also requires that your
soul is a certain way so you didn't
answer whether you actually wanted to
learn touch the air huh
I did want to learn well that's another
thing I also you know when I wanted to
grad school I had tried to attend she
had left it like a class yeah the guy
who was teaching it had some sort of
religious conversion experience and so
like you know he would do like it was
supposed to be an hour long classmates
been like five minutes teaching us so so
movements that I was listless with heaps
of himself talking about she is
all this stuff and whatever reaction you
learn not do it okay so back to this
reason is the smallest part of ourselves
the desires are are the biggest part
right and the spirited part is to serve
the middle part but if the person is
really functioning well reason is
calling the shots now notice it doesn't
mean you get rid of your desires you're
always going to have desires
doesn't mean they can get rid of this
spirited part of yourself but reason is
the thing that determines their limits
and reason means that spirited part of
soul because it's a lie to control the
happiness because you've all had this
experience right you did something
because you had desires to do that thing
and you know it was the wrong thing to
do and even while you were doing this
why am I doing this this is wrong well
that was a case where we use it in the
desires were in conflict and reason
didn't he have that spirited part of the
soul as its ally
reason isn't going to win reason needs
you might think of it as the rulers need
the police to help keep the unruly
people in line because your appetite
through your desires are like unruly
people they want what they want they
want it now they don't take no for an
answer
somebody has to step in and
or Steve that work so if you didn't your
soul doesn't have this sort of structure
Plato says you're going to be again and
fumbling you're going to probably be
unjust when people do the wrong thing
it's not always just because their
desires go crazy it's because reason
isn't working right walk in times people
do really wrong things in part because
reason is working for the desires you
know if you have bezel you come up with
some great land and that's make tons of
money you're pretty smart your reason is
actually being used it's nothing to use
your goods it's being used in the
service of Unruh unrestrained appetites
if you devote great you know ingenuity
to seducing your your friends wife or
husband or something like that
and you think it out you figure out you
know this will he or she really likes
your designers are calling the shots
and they're using reason it's just a
tool and then you end up being unjust
you can also go wrong with the spirit of
partners yeah you know you're so
obsessed with how people think about you
and you know competing with other people
for praise prestige pride that sort of
thing reason could just become a tool of
that too right I mean you might actually
be a kind of better person can suppress
the appetite so you don't look like a
bad person but you know it's still not a
good state still be liable to do bad
things that here's where it gets really
interesting
so in book 1 a book - who's above
justice right and the question was why
should we be just
you're assuming as well the rulers tell
you what to do you better do it the
rulers tell you that's justice they walk
in and out a man says well do you want
to be just so other people don't follow
your data example and the unjust in you
you're afraid of other people driving
you so even though you don't like to be
just you'll be adjust and it severely
instrumental good here's a response to
that
that's what virtue ethics has tested to
say is response to think about your own
life you are probably not exactly latest
I'm right I'm trying to do this
have you experienced they had
consequences coming from unrestrained
desires this experience doing the wrong
thing at times you know it's like to be
pulled in a lot of different directions
right
are you happy when you know what the
right thing is and you find yourself
doing other things instead
the courage does it feel that they have
a life thing you mean like fillet the
critic times they go the unjust person
is in some respects happy because they
may get what they want but in other
respects they're profoundly funny
and the only way to truly be happy is
the plaintiff to be just so why do you
just just to keep yourself out of
trouble
no because if you actually want to
experience the good life a really good
life not just what appears to be not
just what's a beer commercial you know
give up beer commercials what's a good
life pretty good a beer commercial and a
beer first a lot what opens what happens
when you open a beer a beer commercial
it's a party which means what's up
ladies come out you know there's
actually a few girls usually they're
oriented towards men because men are
mostly buying a beer but there's
something to worry intent twist we have
an MMA they have a drink and suddenly
there's always attractive men and all
this great stuff happens that's that's
one for a little while is that all life
ok live a life like that that's not what
it is to be just to be judged means to
actually get integrated human being so
that different parts of who you are are
getting war with each other
I'm just person isn't a certain sense a
fragmented person a person who's at war
with himself
and if it doesn't get better as things
go along it's not like with Plato's
virtue of it's not like you just sort of
yeah you get older it's all gonna make
sense to you would actually have to make
some decisions if you saw this is being
correct you'd have to make some
decisions to become just you would have
to say we're done I need to work on this
and it requires a lot of work and effort
so we I mean that's one of the problems
with